in bonn findet ab montag tatsächlich die
große un klimakonferenz statt wir
schalten wir live zu tina hausten die
für uns die vorbereitung begleitet tina
sie stehen da jetzt am deutschen
infostand was sollen die besucher denn
von uns bitte lernen
gute frage und das offizielle deutsche
klima motto lautet in diesem jahr weg
wenn du absolutely nischt große
klimaziele noch größer verbocken da
werden natürlich viele internationale
gäste leide fragen wenn spaniens ihr
alten klima nazis wie habt ihr das denn
so gar nicht hingekriegt
das wollte ich auch gerade fragen na ja
da gibt es natürlich ein ganzes bündel
von maßnahmen die wir nicht ergriffen
haben beispiel kohleausstieg wir
produzieren immer mehr kohle strom und
einen großteil davon exportieren wir
dann einfach warum magath ihn gar nicht
brauchen und wir haben es sogar
geschafft im straßenverkehr seit 1990
überhaupt keine treibhausgase
einzusparen
in deutschland einst klima toll aber
dann müssen wir jetzt doch auch aufhören
überhaupt klima ziele festzulegen wann
blamiert sich ja es ist eine blamage nur
unsere umweltministerin ja die hat das
noch nicht kapiert diese ihre oma wollte
neulich einen echten klimaplan
verabschieden so mit ganz konkreten
zahlen und einer deadline
wir sind so ein bisschen gebremst worden
wir hatten hier oder da schon so feste
ziele genannt also auch zahlen definiert
da wollte das kanzleramt das nicht so
immer unsere zahlen also haben wir da
xxx rein geschrieben
xxx quizfrage was hat 3x und ist bald
arbeitslos barbara hendricks seine
umweltministerin die sich ernsthaft für
die umwelt einsetzt also manchmal ja
aber die mutter von jimi hendrix hat
auch völlig recht sowie die rdx so wie
wir das machen wird klimapolitik zur
vahr bingo orly war die klimakatastrophe
ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten
ich sage meiner tochter immer pause du
kannst alles werden was du willst aber
beeil dich du hast vielleicht ich sag
mal 20 30 jahre ernsthaft jetzt es ist
nicht mehr zu schaffen also haben wir
spaß was soll der geiz alles raus was
keine miete zahlt auch das co2
berufsleute heizung und klimaanlage auf
volle pulle
egal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viel spaß
[Applaus]